يتدخل في الحياه والموت لوهله تبدو هذه
فرضيه مجنونه لكن في الحقيقه قد تكون
واقعيه باحثون اجروا دراسه جديده حول
روبوت محدثه المثير للجدل ونشروا نتائجها
في مجله سينتفق وفق الدراسه فان رجلا
بلجيكيا انتحر بعدما شجعه برنامج دردشه
اليه تابع لذكاء الاصطناعي على ذلك رجل
اخر انتحر ايضا بسبب علاقه غراميه وهميه
مع البرنامج انتهت بالفشل الدراسه نقلت
روايات كثيره تفيد بان البرنامج يظهر
علامات غير طبيعيه قد تؤثر على سلوك
المشاركين فمثلا هو يخبر احيانا الاشخاص
بضروره تركي زواجهم الدراسه حللت كذلك بعض
الاجابات المثيره للجدل للبرنامج الذي تم
تدريبه على ملايين الاحتمالات والاجابات
فحين سئل عما اذا كان قتل شخص واحد لانقاذ
خمسه اخرين امرا صائبا ام خاطئا كانت
اجابته في كل مره متناقضه